slightly different very different online
game I know you're a big fan of the
gears war franchise you haven't paid the
beta no no I watched some footage from
the beta Brad went and laid it for us so
yeah I did check it out I the
competitive multiplayer is kind of like
the least interesting thing about gears
to me really point so it's sort of like
it's a beta and I think it looks all
right but it's I want to see what
they're doing with cooperative play I
see the campaign I want to see the
future Phoenix yeah and what each Sun
Fenix yeah all that stuff yeah you know
gears were kind of just at some point
turned into the rolling shotgun video
game and or maybe kinda always was that
and it's just it's not it's not what I'm
looking for out of competitive
multiplayer and it seems like they're
you know like Brad even said at the
event that they kind of acknowledged
that that was the thing and like
gnashing righty time' that cover based
know like literally just rolling really
like growing up behind someone and
shooting it with a shotgun and they're
dead and you're like well that's not fun
yeah so yeah it's kind of just it's that
style of play the style of play in
higher level gears play is not something
i was looking to get into your seems
like their solution for it is to add
better bots and already like instead of
like making the game friendlier to a
wider array of people it seemed like
they were like no gears is going to stay
gears which is probably the right move
but you know you can always play against
bots which is doesn't sound like a
solution yeah that's one of the three
modes they have on this this beta i
played waiver for about an hour this
morning you've plated you're up to like
level 10 yeah i mean i was i was playing
over the weekend and had issues with
just servers people weren't playing it
alright so that's I don't happen why
play the game and then I'd be like oh
there's still a lot of people here and I
realized on it's me it's just me against
bots yeah that was frustrating but yeah
I mean it's it's a closed press paid at
the moment it's opening up for people
who bought Ultimate Edition in the next
couple of days no I actually misspoke I
told you earlier it is a lot if you have
bought an ultimate ition supposedly you
can play right now it's in early access
they're rolling at the keys about it
yeah so I some people may 25th it's free
open beta hooray yeah well next one so
you're you're in the same boat as Jeff
right word you would like super into
this thing
in the series and not run so much as a
multiplayer yeah exactly i mean it was
just co-op you know like my brother and
I played although that's all was and and
this time around starting off on the
weekend was frustrating because it makes
more sense that you're getting the spill
of all the ultimate edition guys right
playing online heaven totally yeah and
they're just wrecking you yeah and
eventually as I got to lie got my
placement lohegaon do they basically
said well you suck so we're putting you
in bronze it's a rocket legal / yeah and
so then I'm getting you know like Tokyo
cup of quad kills like oh this is
getting pretty fun and it is all shotgun
and at its heart it's just a bare-bones
beta experience like you're just getting
these basic weapons like the LT only
introduce one new weapon was to drop
shot right yeah like a it's like I'm
half minelayer half rocket launch that's
a grenade launcher with like no distance
is ok but regardless everyone's kills
fool the ones will just run around the
shotgun because you know it's a power
weapon map you know you're going for
power weapons do you want to go for
those all the time do you want to you
know be risky out risk/reward exactly so
that was the one thing I found actually
about it which was I don't know equal
parts sort of like what I was looking
for and also cleared he wasn't what I
really wanted was at this gate this
feels so much like I'm just picking up
Gears of War through my god well like if
you think about the popularity of gears
and like this is kind of one of the
things you could look at like this is
what eSports is doing two games to a
certain extent is like if the rules are
the rules and right you can't make
football suddenly have five downs
instead of four you can't necessarily
like take gears of war and completely
remove the shotgun you know it's popular
enough with a crowd that want to play it
at a high level competitively that you
have to do right by them no matter what
that means for your larger audience yeah
and i think that's that's maybe the the
push and pull of kind of competitive
multiplayer where it's gone when with it
becoming more serious is that you have
more games that are more willing to kind
of leave the wider player base out in
the cold God that seemed so strange
unlike I wonder if there will be a lot
of people who cuz I like I did not enjoy
my time with this it was it you know I
got once I figured out like okay I've
you know distance you need to get like a
one shot shotgun Kayla once I you know I
picked up a torque bow and the first
time I fired I got someone
I was like all right this still works
like I'm enjoying this and I'm you know
the melee stuff is fun and but then I
was just so taken aback by how this
feels it just too close to before and
yeah but like made I did not play
Ultimate Edition so I don't know if yes
is very very close to that and also it
is issues like that oh yeah like same
framework which that's that those are
the changes they made to ultimate
edition over like the original gears one
was they brought in multiplayer stuff
from like let you know spotting and some
other stuff that was in you know later
gears games so Ultimate Edition if you
don't like competitive gears it's real
bummer yeah they're competitive gear
scene yes absolutely this gnashing stuff
again is just it's like an exploit that
that I guess was always present in Gears
where you did you just use the cover and
you do this glitch move bouncing up and
down up here hallway and I see that I
don't even know how to respond to it
there so fast I'd like getting around
called cheating the animation of sliding
in and ends you know like a there was a
chunk of time there probably around
gears to that I was pretty good at
competitive gear yeah for what it was at
the time kirsten was great and I guess
got to a point with it where I was like
I'm actually not really enjoying this
like you know and so I fell away from it
and but people kept on and kept getting
better and better better and better it's
slipping up behind you with that shotgun
and I can you blow up and you're like
all right this is actually frustrating
what happens to me I also don't
necessarily enjoy doing it to my people
yeah I just you know I love horde mode
right I hope that they do something good
with a wave based survival or something
in gears for and a Michigan story but
you know this this beta just kind of I
look at it and go like okay that's they
they're doing what you wholly expect
them to do and and that's great for some
segments of people it's just it's just
not for me yeah yeah and you and you
know it was frustrating like last Friday
when they when I got to get the get into
it was you know just putting down
division and moving into that oh sure
like oh my god control you know I got to
use the d-pad to switch my weapon like
the the thing that got me the most
frustrating was was frustrated was just
the Brody run and having the camera
shake so much like it makes sense for a
cinematic co-op sure like like level of
play when it yeah we did the competitive
nature of it was like
I can't see anyone and then I have to
slow down and do this really slow loss
off man you just can't take gear I can't
cure I can't wait was made yeah for the
hardcore east board gamer I'm kind of I
don't know I'm I think after playing
this I'm I've realized that oh actually
I may be a bit more interested in what
the single player has to offer yeah
maybe that is actually where cuz i paid
a lot of like here's one two and three
online i love those games to pieces and
but you're right like one of the weird
things about I feel like so many shares
is that they rarely ever change any of
the fundamentals but the one thing that
leads to do is try to introduce new game
modes right they can like sort of add in
supplemental ones and they don't
necessarily interfere with the purity
yeah and in this they've they've added a
new bern cards one yeah which which is
this you're right they actually did it
but they at least its tone down where
it's just an experience boost right yeah
it's not like dooms where you guys spot
your last I hate that card so i
fascinate him yeah whatever was
basically punishes you for getting
people Owen yeah but they've also added
in this like game mode which is it's
it's basically like I don't they call
the dodgeball right but it's still like
I feel like just a lengthening of play
it's to death match but you know the
rules by which people come back are
different yeah you kill someone you get
a respawn if you got a sizable back yeah
yeah yeah that it does not work in
Europe yeah but not know I was acting
like dodgeball and I was like oh yeah
you have no idea of course the movie
like yes exactly like the my god okay
that's a middle school gym like
requirement you can judge if you knock
somebody out you get one of your guys
back in okay that's why it's dodgeball
right which is seems which is not also
also not Universal rules for all forms
of doctors well by the way so let's chew
it I was like where I kind of think
about it go like well that's never how I
played dodgeball like okay yes are you
hit him so hard that they could never
come back and we're coming back there
was no coming back so it just seems like
that's like if that's the one mode
you're adding in for the beta it's like
so piecemeal like they've literally just
change like one or two other things but
you know but but at some point they're
actually probably running a beta rice
okay Brandon gears game Oh AB Asia you
know they probably need to actually get
some real telemetry they need to get
some proper data from the people playing
it make sure it all works yeah so at
some point you say like yeah here
play the deathmatch mode in Gears a
bunch like you're going to do anyway and
we'll be able to make sure that this
thing actually functions yeah so I bet
that there is that aspect to it and they
probably have like a cadence of
marketing releases of where the actual
new modes will come from and all that
stuff so yeah it's not too surprising
that they would just take this beta
angle like look you bought the one that
was the remake of the thing right there
was us getting our legs under us in
making a Gears game for this new
platform what's your place and death
match I don't know I hope they also use
the beta to make the graphics up better
as well because some of that stuff's
pretty rough yeah well it also like that
was a weird one where we went to the
event and Microsoft provided capture
equipment right and it captured at 30
frames a second are you kidding you're
like so one thing to get my 720 this is
yeah this is your own gear like this is
your own chance to like to make the game
look as good as it possibly can but you
just pulled out whatever you had in the
blue ossett there's some capture
hardware like we own capture equipment
that is capable of capturing writers and
but because they provided it we didn't
want our stuff it was just looking at it
go like I this mistakes were made I dad
it looks very good on the stream at all
just because it's in 30 and then also
you got all that compression happening
but even even even just looking at it
bear which I have not done so I've only
seen that footage of it but it sounds
like I've seen stills from it and just
looked at a goalie still not quite like
perfect dark zero wall guys I've stuff
like some of that looks pretty rough
real muddy which is a shame I mean it
it's hard to expect like the same sort
of you know amazing graphical oomph that
came with like the original gears and
gears to then especially with like those
games up to that was like HD gaming is
here and not to give them like nine more
outs but you know at some point you are
downloading a beta they do have a good
reason yes try to keep the file size
down for beta because they're paying for
all that bandwidth so maybe they shipped
low res textures you know there's
there's a bunch different stuff that
become becomes a little harder to judge
against a final game when we're looking
at a beta and I always hate like talking
about betas in these terms but somet so
much of betas it seems now in the modern
day is about
marketing is about getting people's
literally it's hey you bought this other
game and now right what you get to play
this next one early yeah otherwise why
would you bought this contract body
react of gears one so um but on it I
mean if it's something to get people
excited then none of us are particularly
excited about at least a multiplayer
side of it ya know I I really like the
teaser trailer with Margaret Enix grow
in that tree and while we did Mel for me
using not yet and than anything in this
beta run into that tree yeah but yeah it
for so so at least like coming out of
all of this if you take all of it
together right I am back on board and
interested in a Gears game which is
something I would not have said coming
out of judgment okay yeah hotels that
judgment was lame the most also ran of
also runs so so at least they're kind of
there on a track I can look at this and
go like yeah man here's for let's do it
let's see where this goes looking
forward to coming out later this year
thank you so much chef for coming on and
talking back here's for that's why we
got you on here exactly yeah and thanks
everyone for watching no let us know
what you think of Gears of War for Gears
of for you excited have you played the
beta are you looking forward to getting
into the better let us know in the
comment box below